Jacob is in Mobile Alabama welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Jacob how can I
help yes
I just have a question my mother-in-law
for the for the past few for the past
year has been trying to she's been
asking us for money for several things
and she's what you would call a a travel
agent for guilt-trip mm-hmm and she and
she likes to pull that card and stuff
and she hardly has a relationship with
her with my wife her daughter and
doesn't and hardly ever wants to spend
time with her and she keeps asking us
for money and like I said pulling the
whole guilt trip thing what should I do
how old are you guys I am I am 22 she is
20 mm long have you been married we'll
be we'll celebrate our one-year
anniversary this Sunday okay all right
and what's your household income okay
I'm gonna send you a book called
boundaries as my gift from dr. Henry
cloud and it talks about how to set up
relationship boundaries now I will warn
you ahead of time that when someone
doesn't respect your boundaries like
this lady with her daughter okay when
you tell her no when her daughter tells
her no she's not going to react well to
that oh I know that okay so you guys
have both got to just set your backbone
and set your jaw so to speak steel
yourself if you've ever heard that term
in terms of like steel like iron and
steel like steel yourself against the
storm brace yourself for the storm that
will come because this lady does not
take no for an answer
comes to taking things from other people
okay so when your daughter tell when her
daughter your wife tells her no mom we
love you but we're unable to help you
any further financially at this time I'm
so sorry
I'd like to but I can't I've got so many
priorities here I mean we're just we're
just kids ourselves we just got married
we don't have we don't have any room for
that I'm so sorry but I love you so much
and I hope it works out for you mom
and when she tells her that this lady's
gonna go ballistic okay so as long as
you're ready for that that's the proper
answer no is a complete sentence or yes
and now now having said that if you
wanted to get a little bit more
sophisticated about your answer to where
you can but I don't think it will matter
and that is as you guys are a little
older and as you've been married a
little longer and as you make more money
you don't make enough money to give
anybody money yeah except maybe tithing
at your church while you're working on
growing your career you guys are below
the poverty level yeah
and so we got to work on your career and
get your all's incomes up and you're not
in a position to support another
household I mean you didn't call me up
making 170 thousand a year you called me
up making seventeen thousand a year so
the answer is absolutely no you cannot
help her because you're not strong
enough financially to help her you can't
agree you can't afford to give her ten
dollars you don't have that kind of
margin in your budget okay so um anyway
we're gonna set the boundary with her
later on when you guys are making really
good money when you are making 100 to 70
if you want to help her then the thing
you got to do is you can't just give
somebody money in these situations you
have to give them money only if they do
things to better themselves because
otherwise you're giving a drunk a drink
yeah you can't you can't give an
alcoholic 20 bucks because what do they
do they go spin on booze and they get
drunk again right and so instead if
you're if you love the alcoholic you
don't give them money and walk away if
you love them you help maybe pay for the
rehab
pay for their counseling or something
but that's real love the same things
true with money you pay for somebody to
get a financial coach or go to Financial
Peace University or give them a total
money makeover book and when you're
doing those things mom we might give you
some money for bills and we'll pay the
bills directly but that's only much much
later that's at least five years from
today for the next five years you can't
give this woman a dime yeah you can give
her a card that says I love you happy
Mother's Day that's all she gets and let
me help you with this too okay
I've got a 26 year my youngest is 26 and
he just got married to 24 okay the
chances of them having to support me
under any circumstances are zero when a
mother comes to a 20 year old daughter
married to a would you say 23 year old
making 17,000 and is asking for money
this woman is a special kind of breed
okay that's like untenable
that's just immoral as crap okay what
kind of parent comes and sucks money out
of a situation like that not one this is
a parasite okay now you don't need to be
mean to her or anything like that but
I'm trying to tell you you're not crazy
you're not wrong and you can gently
calmly even though she's not gonna be
gentle or calm and her reaction say no
and you need to okay yep Jacob if you
need more help you call me anytime I'm
here for you brother hold on Lauren's
gonna pick up we'll get you a copy of
Henry clouds book out and you to you and
your new wife read that it'll help you
you've got a lot of work to do